people choose to detox after the
holidays by abstaining from alcohol for
the month of January AKA dry January
some local restaurants are offering some
help and to tell us more about that we
have David de Leon and Robert Morgan
fall thank you both for being here today
thank you for having us thanks for
having us with click and tailgate
respectively which is a restaurant
inside Palace Palace Station a bar
sports bar kind of yeah so tell us the
idea behind mocktails what what uh LED
you guys to do this so let's just steer
away from like especially with our
holidays that we just had
um just trying to keep it
arms
spirit-free yeah so right here we have
uh lychee strawberry and lemon mocked
out that we are going with and then we
do have our runoff of a bellini which is
a peach and Sprite with the garnish of a
rosemary and blackberry
and so normally what alcohol would you
throw in without pretty well pretty much
anything I would say with this one just
because the champagne flu I would say uh
Prosecco okay so just to
make it look pretty yeah and are people
going to notice the difference
other than nothing not really that's a
good part of it yeah they taste
identical and people love it and you can
join the party it's not like you know I
need to have a soda and I feel like kind
of out let me just get water here you
have a really cool cocktail taste
delicious great garnish it looks like
you're drinking a cocktail so you kind
of in with the party right right we like
to call them zero proof Libations yeah
and it allows people to keep their
resolution for Beyond maybe five or six
days
only one day at the gym yeah you went to
the gym day one it was packed it was
packed it was like Amateur hour at the
gym day two Tuesday was no one there yet
they kept it for one day one day well
this helps people beyond that and it's
happening at three different locations
is that right correct if you have that
Hearthstone which is that we're at Red
Rock and the two locations we have at
the Green Valley Ranch abutia and
buracha okay but not a tailgate not a
tailgate oh okay yeah
all right so which one do you have here
so this one is are the lychee okay it's
just strawberry lychee and lemon juice
and uh just to get it off I'm a 45th
empty food right after top it off with
Red Bull I mean you don't have to use
the red but you can always substitute
out with like soda or something yeah
though it's not for the kids I mean the
kids right right yeah and then
pour it in this bad boy right here
how long you been bartending now for
about four years four or not four and a
half years all right and now uh manager
right yeah that's fantastic all right so
can I sample it here oh we gotta top it
off yeah add the Red Bull first put a
little proof from there right yeah so
are you going to continue these
throughout January and Beyond or is this
just the month we'll stole it generous
see kind of how they How They Roll I
mean people want them they're on our
menu so we have no problem keep on going
February March maybe dude quarter
quarter one and you know Sony's
cocktails or even four yeah for children
right maybe not this Red Bull one right
everyone else and it's great for you
know for upselling purposes for
restaurants right and service and
bartenders to make a little bit extra
money instead of getting that soda for
for the child yeah hey man ask your
parents hey can you try one of these
specialty [ __ ] that we have is there a
proof of course live Asians right and
you know they're very sweet tasty this
is fantastic what's this one again that
one's the lychee lychee love it okay
Robert David thank you so much for
joining so thank you for helping
everybody with dry January of course